Here's how to play the Golden Girls drinking game
You will need
Up to 3 other friends
Your favorite alcoholic beverages
and an episode of the best Bea Arthur based sitcom of all time
No, not Maude. Come on.
First everyone chooses a character
Next, agree on a mode of play.
There are 2 possible modes
Zing or Get Zinged
When playing Zing, you drink every time your character zings someone.
I treat my body like a temple
Yeah, open to everyone. Day or night! *Cash register bell sound*
When playing Get Zinged, you drink every time your character gets zinged.
I treat my body like a temple
Yeah, open to everyone. Day or night! *Cash register bell sound*
You can tell who the alcoholics are because they choose Sophia when playing Zing
Or Rose when playing Get Zinged.
Watch the episode and drink with every zing
taking shots based on your character and these special circumstances
Whenever Sophia says, "Picture it"
Picture it! Sicily, 1922.
Whenever Dorothy gives advice
You should have a home field advantage, why don't you invite him over here.
Whenever Blanche mentions Big Daddy
I haven't had to disappoint so many men since Daddy tore down the treehouse.
Or whenever Rose says a strange word from St. Olaf.
As they say in St. Olaf, "Helderbargenblargenflur"
Then there's the Cheesecake Rule
If your character sits at the table eating cheesecake, you have to finish your drink and start another.
And finally, everyone must sing the theme song during the credits.
*Singing* Your heart is true, your a pal and a confidante
Please drink responsibly and thank you for being a friend.
*drunken singing of the Gold Girls theme song*